ae deixei meu carro e me mexer papo na
não pague gente cheguei dof a oi como
vai você e aí a gente melhorar quando
vocês gente eu cheguei de viagem agora
tentam índice em casa tal índice teve um
vídeo atrai gente nem vocês arrumar fica
muito rápido era só pegar um só joga se
na cama prontas como futuro está
perfeito agora fala que não tem um rui
só que cada casa toda
eu já estava na mina ea galera sou eu
para se eu penso meu deus eu moro na
quitinete que é um lugar tão pequeno eu
nunca consigo para arrumar o meu parto é
feito pensando meu deus como foi que não
aguentou marcado inteira pra todo mundo
até hoje jesus que tinha mãe muito
obrigado feito muito mas muito obrigado
a ter um carro muito bem muito obrigado
a idade com direito a lances assim para
podermos ganhar não para me acostumar né
eu estava lá no facebook é como sempre
andando lá de borracha nas postagens era
posta gente vocês também estão recebendo
uma ligação do número que comece com 0
não sei o que você quer fazer um pacto
com diado coloca como é que está a um do
ônibus que as pessoas têm ligação do
capeta para fazer pacto com ele eu fui
pensando que é amargamente é tão difícil
a pessoa fazer um pacto com o diabo é
que ele correrá da galinha preta e ponha
no mercado comprar velas pretas ela
vermelho bela branca diante de drogba o
vendedor já confessa ela pretende lançar
venha pra quem manda sou eu o amo eu tô
só um fazer um vaio marcou maneira mas
depois eu vou tentar fazer o que não vai
mais usar aqui e eu estou falando
gostava que foi uma bomba e depois o
vovô está de volta e por que procurar
introduzir a quem levar a linha pretende
levar velho leva a cachaça levar farofa
e dinheiro para inclusive a de fazer
isso tudo kaká
antigamente era tão difícil você tem
algum contato com o capeta hoje em dia o
carro tá aqui ele página velho falei
para não vender seu lado e 4 xi e
oitenta reais no paraíba agora tá um
satanás tem agora a galera do satanás
está ligando para as pessoas para saber
se ele quer fazer pacto com o diabo é
porque eu espero já falou ou então
espero ter um aplicativo da pec toda a
sua energia quando se acede o ministro
brasileiro aplicativo apita la paz
o badoca que há muito eu liguei para
fechar o contrato a bola no meio passou
de cantar devendo o negócio também acha
mesmo sacanagem sair lá da sata nice
dele para ele a faz pessoa gastar os
créditos desde já teve gente que falou
que é o negócio a roubar informação
roubar foto da barriga teve gente que
falou que o negócio de uma cartomante
seguida e só começou scut até gente
falou que chuva os seus créditos se você
apenas a ligação pode de fato é que
ninguém sabe então se um saco na barriga
pra não ser fácil porque é oi sa finais
não daqui não falou então fato é esse o
número que ligar pra você começar do
zero 6565 não sei o que ele o número que
tenha muitos 65 no mês e não atende deve
ser trote alguma coisa assim eu quero
você comente aqui embaixo se o satanás
ligado pra você o que você falaria tá aí
então quero que você comente aqui em
baixo e isso aí é que você escolheria os
atuais a ligação a galera de uma coisa é
certa e essa eu tenho certeza
reza a lenda que se você não clicar em
gosto nesse vídeo eu vim de noite foi
chefe de estado ter o seu culto à espera
que eu comprei mas para que eu comprei
ela fez para que eu comprei um poder
matar
a unha e olha só um recadinho o senhor
rapidinho eu tenho parceria com a cá
muita lógica que vem depois do sport vem
de skate e vende roupas veio um monte de
acará de coisa e é um link na descrição
do vídeo o primeiro na descrição do
vídeo que é na loja lá então se você
quiser alguém está na loja e comprar
qualquer coisa é nós pa com esse link na
descrição do vídeo usando meu ocupam
esse cupom aqui ó
é hora de na hora de comprar chegam até
60 de desconto em qualquer produto e é
nós e velho